- Hi, good morning.
How's everyone today?
Good?
Excellent.
So first of all, thank you
so much for joining us today.
Before we start the session,
think about that you are a chef
and you want to prepare
a dish for your friend
because it's his birthday.
As a chef, you have the end goal in mind,
which is the dish that your friend likes.
But through the course of preparation,
there are so many steps involved.
You have to get good-quality
food, the spices,
the temperature needs to be right,
and you have to put the
ingredients in the right order.
And finally, there is a
dish that your friend likes.
So when we think about data engineering,
it's nothing different.
You have the end goal in
mind to build a scalable,
reliable data pipeline with quality
that serves your business use case
so you can make the
decision at the right time.
But with data pipeline, there
are so many steps involved.
You need to catalog the data,
you need to profile the data,
and then you have to build the jobs,
you have to orchestrate it,
you have to deploy it in production,
and then provide it to the end users
for reporting or to serve them.*
But what if through each of those steps,
there is an agent which works
as a pair programmer for you.
So this is our session today,
to walk you through
agentic data engineering
using AWS analytical MCP servers.
I'm Harshida Patel,
a principal specialist
solution architect from AWS.
And joining me today is Ram Nottath,
who is a principal solutions
architect with data and AI.
Okay, thank you so much, Ram.
So this is our journey for this session.
We'll start off with the
data engineer's pain points
and the challenges they run into,
followed by using agentic
AI as the solution,
with model context protocol.
Then we will do a demo, share
with you best practices,
and how you can deploy
this in production at scale
and share resources that
you can walk away with.
So let's get started with meet AnyCompany,
which is a fictitious retailer.
They want to transform their business
by transforming their customer experience
by tapping into the data.
They have a very clear
vision and a mission,
that they want to put data
to work and make an impact.
So they start off with
a solid data strategy,
where data is the foundation.
They want to build scalable,
analytical pipelines
with quality to serve
the growing use cases.
But their main goal is
to provide this insight
into the hands of the
decision-maker at the right time
so they can make a data-driven decision.
So this is their vision and their mission.
But when we check the reality,
it's completely different.
A marketing team reaches out
to the data engineers and say,
"This is a new promotional analysis
that we want to build
and get insight into.
Can you build a data pipeline for this?"
They say it's going to
take two to three weeks.
The operational team wants
to get near real-time insight
into the inventory.
The data engineer shares,
"Our data pipeline is already
lagging three to five days."
The executives want to automate
the Monday morning report
so they can make the
decisions at the right time,
but it's still a manual refresh.
So this is impacting the marketing team,
the operations teams, the executives.
So the bottom line, it's
impacting the revenue
because the decisions
cannot be made on time.
When you further deep dive into
and ask the data engineers,
"What is the cause for this productivity,
or what is the cause for this delays?"
And I would ask, like,
love to ask you a question.
Does any of this resonate
with any of you, right?
Context switching
starting with number one.
So when you get the data
engineers get the requirement,
they want to embed a new
feature within their product.
So they search through the code,
they try to understand the
code, there is no documentation.
Once they understand the requirement,
they go and do web search to
figure out the best practices
to write the code,
figure out how this particular
feature in AWS really works.
Then they start developing the code,
writing things from scratch.
And while they are writing and
focusing on the development,
there is a data analyst
which sends an alert
that the key performance
indicators for today
are completely off.
So they start debugging, they
start looking at the data,
and they finally figure
out after hours of effort
that there is a source data quality issue.
So we missed an entry in the dimension.
So when you're joining to the fact,
it's not able to relay
the key performance indicator metrics.
So again, data quality is more
reactive, it's not proactive.
They go back.
Once the data is fixed,
they go back to do the development.
But then there is an alert
that the data pipeline today is very slow.
It's not performing.
So again, the data engineer
switches the focus,
figures out what the
performance issues are,
and then tries to go to the web search.
How do you optimize this pipeline?
And this is where the time gets lost.
So all of these things are piling up.
Then one fine day, Sarah Chen,
who is the CTO of data
engineering, sends an email
that we are missing to provide
the data insights to the marketing team,
the operations team, as
well as the executive team.
Sarah heard from one of her
friend at another retailer
that they are able to
see productivity gain
while building the data pipeline
using data engineers using agentic AI.
So Sarah asked the team whether
we continue to do something
which is not working, or
radically shift the direction.
So let's work backwards
from what the ask is
and see what is possible.
Let's use this use case of a
traditional data engineering
versus with agentic data engineering.
So let's go back that the
developer or the data engineer
got the requirement,
find the retail customer
dataset, process it,
check the demographics, validate it,
and upload it to a data
warehouse for reporting.
So, what does a data engineer do?
If the dataset is cataloged,
they would go to the catalog,
they would search the location,
they will be able to able
to find out the column,
the corresponding data type.
Once they have identified,
they start writing the code from scratch,
they deploy it, they run it.
If there is an error, they fix it.
Then they write a SQL
to validate that dataset
just to look at, are there null values?
Are there 50 states in the dataset?
Then they write a Python code
to load this into a data warehouse.
Versus with agentic data engineering,
what if for each of the step,
instead of writing and typing
and going through the console,
it's converted into a natural language.
So first, find the
retail customer dataset.
Once you find it, create
a Glue job, deploy it.
If there are errors, you fix it.
You validate the dataset.
And then you finally load
it to a data warehouse.
So the manual process of clicking through,
converting that through
agentic data engineering
by asking questions in
the natural language,
and have the agent do
the work on your behalf.
So, how is this possible?
This is where the agentic
loop comes into play,
where you have an agent
where we exactly ask the same question
for the retail customer dataset,
process it, validate it,
and upload it to a data warehouse.
This is your question.
Your question becomes
the goal for the agent
It has cognitive insight.
So as a data engineer, once
we get the requirement,
we try to understand
it, we try to plan it,
we try to take action.
Then once the action is performed,
we try to make decisions.
So all of this is the reasoning.
And while the large language
model takes your request,
parses out into multiple steps,
it also needs information.
So it's able to identify,
"I need more data to get more context
to figure out what my next
course of action should be."
So the agents have access to the tools
where they can execute, not only a code,
but also retrieve more information.
And this context goes back to the LLM,
where it's able to see, get,
and perceive from the
new information it got,
and then figures out what
next step it has to take.
So this loop of reasoning,
as well as taking the
action till your goal is met
is what is the agentic loop.
Now let's dive into the building
blocks with the agentic AI.
So agent is in the
center, agent has memory,
it has short term and long-term memory.
The short term memory is for
in the context of your session,
the long-term memory,
think of it as episodic,
what happened in the past,
like your personal diary.
It can also have semantic memory,
where it has the context of your domain
or domain-level knowledge.
The agents has an arm where
it has access to tools.
And the tools are
something that you control,
whether you want to have
a function for the agent
to access your data, your AWS services,
and this could also be external services.
So tools is the action
that the agent can take.
It's calling a function.
The function can be retrieve
the data, run a code,
or invoke an API.
So that's the action.
The agent has brain.
So we talked about reasoning,
the next step is it
identifies multiple steps
that it needs to take to
solve a complex problem.
It takes a step, it gets the insight,
and the results from the tool.
Then it reflects what should
be the next course of action.
So the planning, reflection,
chain of thoughts,
as well as self critiquing.
The main thing is action.
And this is also what you control.
Whether you want all the
actions to be on autopilot,
or you want the human in the
loop for some of the actions.
So an agent, along with the memory,
the planning, the reasoning,
along with the tool is what it automates
and independently to perform
the task that you provide,
which is the goal for the agent.
And for an agent, give it a persona.
So for our talk,
we will give it the
persona of a data engineer.
The goal is to build the data pipeline
and provide the instructions precisely
so it can think better.
Now, let's summarize all of this.
So we talk about agentic loop,
we talked about the building blocks,
but now, let's put a simple
example of a workflow.
So you as a data engineer,
you're asking a question
to build the pipeline
in natural language,
your interaction is with
the agentic assistant.
And then the agentic assistant
is already integrating with
the tools your data sources.
So along with this question,
the tool descriptions are sent
to the large language model.
The large language model,
as it has pared out your complex question
into multiple steps,
it decides whether it
wants a specific tool
or to do a function call.
So it makes the request back
to the agentic assistant
along with so that it can get the context.
The agentic assistant invokes the function
to retrieve the information
from your data source.
It gets the results,
and this results are sent back
to the large language model.
Now, large language model
gets that information
of the results.
Context, it's gonna reflect.
It's gonna figure out
what is going to be the
next course of action.
In our use case, we started off
with retail data customer
dataset, which is on S3.
So it's going to request,
"Find me the list of,
find me the location of
retail customer dataset."
The tool it's going to
call whether it's list S3
or whether if they are using DataZone,
it will invoke any API for DataZone.
The agent calls their tool,
performs that function,
the results are returned,
and that information that,
hey, this is the location
of the S3 dataset
is sent back to large language model.
But the next step, we
need to create a Glue job.
So the large language model
is going to call another set of function.
So this entire loop is dynamic in nature.
It's going to, this loop
is going to continue until,
unless it has all the
information to meet your goal
and provide a final comprehensive
response to the end user.
So we saw that we have agents,
but the agents just with large
language model is not enough.
It needs to have the context,
it needs to have the information,
it needs to perform an action.
So the integration of the AI agents
with the tools and the data
sources becomes important.
So why is this little bit challenging
to integrate the data sources
and the tool with an AI agent?
Let's consider this use case.
You have an AI agent.
When you need to talk to a
data warehouse, it uses SQL.
When it needs to talk
to, say, a Glue catalog
or it needs to do data
processing, it's going to use API.
What if there are specification changes?
Then they have to update
those specification
to adhere to the API.
What if they need to add
another tool or remove a tool?
And this might be simple
if you have one agent.
But when you start creating
N number of agents,
think about the tight coupling
and the integration problem.
And this is all custom integration.
This is N times M custom
integration problem.
So, how do we simplify this?
How do we make it seamless
for the AI agents to discover
what are the data sources
and what are the tools
which are available?
This is where Model Context
Protocol comes into play.
It's a universal language.
So in this example,
you want to add a tool,
you add a function.
If you want to remove a function,
you remove the function from MCP.
If there is an API change,
you make that change in one single place.
Then you can integrate one agent,
or you can integrate N number of agents.
So this makes the integration
standardized integration.
So what is Model Context Protocol?
It's USB-C for agentic AI applications.
And this was invented or
developed by Anthropic.
So let's look at the architecture for MCP.
There is MCP host, the one
with which you are integrating.
There is an application.
You can use an application of your choice.
It could be Amazon SageMaker
Unified Studio, Kiro,
Claude Desktop.
And those application
needs to be MCP-compliant.
So there is the client side,
and these clients are integrating
or communicating with the MCP servers.
And this integration, from
the client to the server,
is known as the transport
layer or communication model.
There are two deployments of MCP servers.
When the MCP server is locally deployed,
where it's using the compute
of where your host is,
that is the local deployment of MCP server
and the communication it uses
is standard input output.
If the MCP server is remote,
it's going to use HTTPS.
Now, the server is the one
that is integrating with
your data sources, your data,
which is in your control.
So the way the MCP server
integrates with the sources,
it could be SQL, it could be API,
it's completely independent,
depending upon the
services that it provide.
So let's take over here as an example.
Say you're working with Kiro,
I'm gonna use Kiro
because it's been announced even yesterday
with a lot of features.
You ask your question, find
the same question, right?
We are gonna repeat throughout the talk
is find me the retail customer dataset,
process it, validate it,
and then load it into the data warehouse.
The large language model, think about it.
It's going to break it
down into multiple steps.
For the first step, it's going to...
And then, because of this
integration of MCP client,
it also has the information
of the tools that it can use.
So the first step is find the
dataset retail customer data.
The tool it wants to use is list S3,
or if there is a data catalog,
go through and search
through the data catalog.
So the client sends the
request to the server.
The server is the one that
is running the function
to integrate with your service.
Then the response is sent back
from the server to the client
and to the large language
model and reaching the context
and it figure out next step.
So what are the components
on the server side?
There are three components.
Tools, consider it, not consider,
it is the functions that
the client can call.
For example, create a Glue
crawler, or create a Glue job.
For example, resources are read-only,
get me the list of all the Glue tables.
And then you have prompts,
which are blueprints or
structured prompt templates.
If you wanna take a picture,
I'll go a slide back.
Okay.
So now we talked about how a agentic AI,
which is the reasoning
and the action in the loop
and the integration with the tools
going to help work independently
to serve a data engineer
to perform the tasks.
The MCP servers,
when you have an analytical tech stack
where you could be
using multiple services,
AWS Glue or Amazon EMR or Amazon
Athena or Amazon Redshift,
this MCP servers, AWS
analytical MCP servers,
think about the first problem
that the developers had,
contact switching.
This MCP servers covers multiple services.
The second is getting the latest
and the greatest
information on the features,
the best practices.
So when the data engineer ask
a question, "Build me a code."
That code will be with quality
because it is aware of the best practices.
When you're trying to build a workflow,
process the Glue job,
and then load this data
into a data warehouse,
it's like workflow orchestration.
So it has the domain knowledge
of the AWS services to work with.
So the MCP servers with AWS
is when you're using Amazon
Glue, Amazon AWS Glue,
or Amazon EMR for your data processing,
or Amazon Athena for interactive query,
there is data processing MCP server.
And the questions a data
engineer you can ask,
"Create a Glue crawler."
And these are only few list
of questions in the list.
We'll also share with you a QR code,
where you can find the
entire list of MCP servers,
along with the tools that it supports.
The LLM is the one which
decides which tool to invoke.
Say, you call Glue crawler.
It knows that there is a
function associated with Glue,
it's going to call that.
But when you start asking
questions on your dataset,
"From the sales data,
identify top 10 products,"
the LLM is aware that,
hey, this is a query,
so it's going to invoke the function,
which is associated with Amazon Athena.
So again, the best practices
integrated with all of this workflow.
When you're using Amazon Redshift,
which is a data warehousing service,
there is Redshift MCP server,
and this Redshift MCP server is read-only.
It provides you the information.
You can say, "List all the
endpoints in my account."
Or if you have two end points
and you want to query
across those two endpoints
on customer information, you
have the ability to do so,
but it's read-only.
If you are using DataZone,
DataZone MCP server, where
you can list and subscribe.
When you're using Amazon
managed streaming for Apache,
think about an admin persona
who wants to create a cluster,
who wants to set the retention log,
who wants to get insight
into the resource monitoring,
so the MCP server for MSK is
more from an admin persona.
When you are using OpenSearch,
the OpenSearch MCP server,
you can list indices,
but you can also ask
questions on your dataset.
Again, this is only a small
list of the MCP servers
and the corresponding
natural language questions
you can ask.
So now, we walk through the theory part,
let's now dive deep into the action
and how to make it possible.
I'd like to hand over to Ram,
but thank you so much for joining us.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Harshida,
for that amazing overview
of the agentic loop and the capabilities
of the various analytics MCP servers.
Just a quick check, am I audible?
All good?
Okay.
All right.
So as a solutions architect,
I do help with multiple customers
to implement data and AI solutions.
When I talk to them, there is
one thing that is consistent,
one requirement that is consistent
across all the customers,
which is the need for data engineering.
And I'm pretty sure we all are
here because of that, right?
Now, let's see the AnyCompany Retail
that we were talking about
is not any different either, right?
So they have the same challenge.
Now, let's take a look
at how we can implement that solution,
which will help you to do this
data engineering much faster.
Here is an architecture
that can help you with that.
This can actually give you
a state-of-the-art data engineering
with agentic capabilities
that Harshida was mentioning earlier.
Now, here, if you look at,
I can see the various MCP
servers coming together
to help the task that a data
engineer would like to do.
There are multiple tasks,
whether it's governance,
whether it's data processing,
whether it's SQL query,
there are multiple things
that a data engineer would want to do.
So these MCP servers come together
to help the data engineer
with those tasks.
Now, let's take a look
a bit more in detail.
Let's start from the left.
So here, the user is
interacting with the MCP host,
the one that Harshida
was mentioning earlier,
and that MCP host could be
any tool of your choice.
It could be SageMaker
Unified Studio or Kiro
or Claude desktop, any of
those MCP-compliant MCP host.
Now once you have an MCP host,
the next thing that you
do is you configure,
whatever MCP servers that
you want to work with.
When you configure that,
it makes a connection between
the host and the server
using the MCP client.
Now, the intelligence part of
this whole agent lies below,
which is the large language model.
And in this case,
we are using Amazon Bedrock's
large language models.
Now, when the user ask a question,
"Hey, this is a task that I want to do,"
LLM interprets what is
the user looking for.
And LLM also understands,
through MCP host and the client,
it also understands that
these are all the tools
that I have at my disposal
and how can I best deliver
the result to the user.
Now, if you remember what
Harshida was mentioning earlier,
there's always a loop, or
it's an iterative process
because we may not get the
answer right at the first one
because there are multiple
steps involved in the task.
So what LLM does is it
uses the first tool,
get the data or do the
first task, get the result,
and then identify what is
the next tool which can solve
or continue solving the
problem that user has asked.
And that iterative process
finally takes you to the final result
what you want to get to.
Now, let's take a look at how
we can configure MCP server
in some of the tools
so that you can get going
with some of these activities.
So here is a screenshot
of how you would do this in
SageMaker Unified Studio.
If you're familiar with
SageMaker Unified Studio,
this is the notebook experience there.
On the left-hand side, you
will see the Amazon Q icon.
And once you click on that,
there is a tool icon on right,
the top of the right corner.
Once you click on that,
that will give you a pop-up
to give the details about the MCP servers
that you wanna configure.
All what you need to do
is provide the name of the MCP server
and couple of configurations,
and you're done.
Now, in this particular case,
I'm configuring data
processing MCP server.
With this simple step,
now you have the capability
to interact with your various
data processing services
in natural language.
Now, let's take a look at how
you would do the same thing
in case of another tool, Kiro.
So it's not any different,
just that in case of Kiro,
there's a mcp.json file.
All what you would do is you have a block
of JSON configuration that you need to add
for each MCP server
that you wanna bring in.
So you might be bringing
in Redshift MCP server
or DataZone MCP server or
data processing MCP server.
For each one of those MCP server,
you'll have a JSON block
that you need to add.
And you might see some
of the auto-approved list
and things like that.
We will cover that later in the session.
But this is how easy that you can can go
and configure the MCP in your
MCP host client that you have,
MCP host application that you have.
Now, let's get a bit more specific
into the task that we have at
hand for AnyCompany Retail.
Let's meet Alex, the
data engineering agent.
Now, Harshida mentioned
the task that we have
for AnyCompany.
We wanna start with,
we want the help Alex.
We wanna start with data discovery.
And we wanna make sure
that Alex is able to go
and find out where is the customer data,
the customer behavior and
customer dimension data files.
And then, we want Alex to
go and create an ETL job.
And in that job,
the activity that we want Alex to perform
is join the two datasets
based on customer ID
and aggregate the data based on state.
And once that is done, of
course, we created the job.
We want Alex to go and run that job.
And it's not just about running,
we want Alex to help us
with monitoring the job
and fixing issues, if there
is anything coming up.
And then we wanna catalog the output.
After cataloging, we want
to do some data validation,
because at the end of the day,
anything that we do need to be validated.
So we need to do some data validation.
And once everything is done,
if you remember the marketing team,
the execs are really looking for the data
in their data warehouse.
So we want the data to be
loaded to data warehouse.
So this is what the data engineering team
at AnyCompany Retail has at hand.
This is a task.
So, let's take a look.
As a first step,
we'll take a look at how
to configure the MCP server
in one of the tools, like Kiro.
So I'm in Kiro, and this is
the lighter theme of Kiro.
Typically, you might have
seen the darker theme there.
So here, I have configured
multiple MCP servers,
data processing, Redshift,
and you'll see the various
tools that are listed.
And you can also see
that other MCP servers
that I've configured,
you can either enable or
disable using a right click.
Now, once you click on that
little icon icon over there,
that's what will open up that JSON file.
So it's a matter of just
adding that little block
of JSON configuration,
so that you can add any MCP server
that you want to bring in.
So that's the data processing MCP server.
And here, you have S3 MCP server.
Here's a Redshift one.
So these are MCP servers
that I've configured.
It's a matter of adding
that particular block.
Once you're done, that's it.
That's all the configuration
that you need to do.
You are good to go
and work with these services
using natural language.
Now, this is the prompt
that we are giving to Alex,
and let's not worry
about all the things
that are written there.
But the major things are, hey, Alex,
you are a data engineering
agent and we need your help
in identifying the dataset
and processing the data.
But one thing here, human
and loop is important.
So after every step,
come and ask me if whatever was done
in the previous step looks fine
so that you can move forward.
So that's a confirmation
that I'm expecting.
So we are asking Alex
to come back and ask,
and then move forward with the six steps
that we just looked at.
I want to go ahead and find the data,
then create a Glue job.
And there, we are becoming
very specific this time.
We want to join based on customer_id,
and I want to get the sum of page views
and total purchase amount and
land the dataset in Parquet.
And, of course, aggregation
is based on the state, right?
And then run the job, fix any errors,
and monitor the job.
Then go and create a crawler
so that we can catalog them.
We can, well, put that
in the same step itself,
in the job creation itself
or job execution itself.
Now, next one is validating the data
using running the queries.
And then finally,
this time we want Alex
to create a notebook
so that we can use that to
load the data into Redshift.
There's a task at hand.
Now, let's move to step one.
So here, we are asking
Alex, "Hey, can you please,"
these are all the steps
that are involved, right?
So, "Hey, you are a
data engineering agent.
These are all the six steps
that we want you to go ahead and run.
But make sure that come and
ask me after each step."
Now, let's take a look.
You can see that the very
first thing that it is doing
is it's picking up an MCP
tool to list S3 buckets.
And it is going and analyzing
the data that is there in S3
because, again, in this particular case,
we have specifically said
that, hey, go and get the
data that is sitting in S3.
Now, in your case, the
data might be sitting in,
it could be in Redshift, it
could be in other places,
or the data might be
cataloged in a data catalog.
So you can use a respective
MCP server's help
to go and scan for the
data, find where it is,
and get that specific data.
So it is able to find the data,
but it is still trying to do something.
You know why?
Because we have asked in the next step,
you need to go and join this
datasets based on customer_id
and go and do the sum of page views
and amount and things like that.
So even though it is
able to find the dataset,
it is still going and verifying,
"Hey, do I have those fields in there?
Because if I don't have those fields,
I cannot really move on to the next step."
So it is thinking ahead
and making sure that those
fields are available.
So it is able to find the
customer_id, customer_name, city,
state, all of those details.
So there you go, step 1 is complete.
So you have the datasets, there's word is,
and then you have the customer_id,
product_id, page views,
all of those details.
All good.
Hey, I'm done with step 1,
can I proceed to step 2?
So, cool, data discovery is done.
Let's move to step 2.
Let's say, "Yes, proceed to step 2."
Okay.
So this time,
the expectation is Alex will
help us creating a Glue job.
Now, to create a Glue job,
first and foremost, if you
look at the first activity
that it is trying to do is
using another MCP tool there
to get the roles.
What that really means is Alex knows
that if it has to create a
job, it needs to understand
that what is a role that
should be used with that job?
Because the role should have access
to the right resources, right?
So it should have access
to the S3 datasets,
it should have access to the
Glue job, Glue resources,
all of those things.
So it is able to get all the data.
And it went ahead and
created a job, a .py file.
So you can see the .py file.
In a real-world scenario,
we should ideally validate
some of these things
before allowing it to run.
So let's assume that
Alex is fine here, right?
Now, it is asking, "Hey, can
I go and upload this to S3?"
And we will talk about
why it is asking us,
"Hey, can I go and upload this?"
Some of them, it went ahead and did that.
But some of the tools
it is coming and asking,
"Hey, can I do this," right?
We'll talk about that a little bit later.
So here, you can see that, yes,
it is using another operation,
which is create-job.
So it made and created the job.
All good.
So it looks like the job
creation is complete,
step 2 is done.
So we have the...
It's making sure that there
is a get-job run, get-job,
to see whether the job
creation when successful.
All good.
So we have the job ready.
Now, we can move on to step 3.
So looks like job creation
is done, let's get to step 3.
So this time, what we are hoping for
is Alex will go and run
this job and monitor it
and fix any error if
there is anything, right?
So this time, it called another tool,
which is manage AWS Glue jobs.
And this time, it is
starting the job here.
So again, think about the
way we would work, right?
So it is thinking ahead
and it is also going
that step-by-step process
that we as data engineers would've done
and giving us the assistance
of what we want to do.
So since it started running the job,
let's get to the Glue console
just to see how things are happening.
So let's go to Glue console.
ETL and runs.
So we can see that the
job is running now, right?
So looks like it's happening.
And if you remember,
what we have told us, it's
not just about running the job
and leaving it out there.
As a data engineer, the agent,
you want to go ahead and monitor it,
so you can see that it is
trying to monitor the job.
And it found that there's
a sleep time of...
It's still running, so it put
a sleep time of 30 seconds.
Now, think about it.
As an end user, what you
may want to do is see,
you may know that, hey,
this job may take one hour.
You don't want the agent to go
and monitor it every 30 seconds, right?
So that is something,
that is where human in the
loop is, again, important here.
So you can guide the agent
what to do, what not to do.
So you can say that,
"Hey, go and monitor the
job after five minutes."
But this is a smaller dataset,
so we let that happen.
So, okay, go ahead and
check every 30 seconds.
So that's okay.
Now we can see that,
hey, the job was done,
but it is able to, if you remember,
we told that, hey, go and
check if there are any errors
and fix it, right?
So it found some error in the logs,
and it is going and checking,
"Hey, is there anything concerning?"
So it went and checked,
and found that, no, there
was an error that was fixed,
so it went, moved forward.
So it is again going back and validating,
"Hey, is everything good?"
So it did a list job Once again,
just list job run once again
to make sure that everything is fine.
Looks like it succeeded and
it took around 83 seconds.
And this is what is the result.
So we have the output
saved in a Parquet format.
Perfect.
So the task force data
aggregation is done.
Now, let's move on to our next one,
which is cataloging it, right?
So this time,
we want Alex to help us with
cataloging this dataset.
So for that, we are asking,
"Hey, Alex, go and create
a crawler and catalog it."
So this time, it is using the MCP tool,
manage-aws-glue-databases,
to find out which Glue database
it can catalog that metadata.
And once it finds that metadata,
the next thing that it is doing
is manage Glue crawler
and creating a crawler.
So here, you can see that it
went and created a crawler,
and it even started that.
So think about how fast
it is going, right?
So we would've clicked
through multiple screens,
created the crawler, started the run.
But by the time we explain
what it is able to do,
you can see that in action.
You can already see that
the crawler is running.
So that is, that is what is
a productivity improvement
that we can gain from these agents.
So here, you can see that
the crawler is running.
Now, if you remember,
we told in the previous step that, hey,
monitor my job, right?
We did not specify anything
when it comes to the Glue crawler.
We do not specify
anything about monitoring.
But it understands that whether it's a job
that is running for data processing
or a crawler that is
running for cataloging,
it's all the same.
The intent is same, right?
So it is trying to monitor by itself
and giving us an idea,
"Hey, is it running fine?"
So you can see that there
are some sleep commands
and all of those things
that it is putting,
and it is validating that,
"Hey, is it running?"
So you can see that now
the crawler is in the stopping state.
So it's validating again to see,
another 15 seconds to
see if it got executed,
if it is complete.
So think about the time
that we would've spent
in a lot of these activities.
And what if you are going
into an important meeting,
starting this pipeline,
coming back and seeing the results, right?
So a lot of these things can be done
by the time you come back.
So here, you can see that
yes, the task is complete.
So you can see the new
crawler that got created
and this is the database
and that's a table that's cataloged.
That's great.
So let's move on.
So we have our data cataloging done,
next comes the validation.
So we are requesting Alex,
"Hey, Alex, can you help us?"
Let's, okay.
"Alex, can you help us
validate this data?"
And this time,
we are just saying, "Validate
by running queries."
We did not say what query,
which server to use,
but this is where the intelligence
comes into picture, right?
So the LLM has an idea which...
There are multiple tools
that are available.
We have configured Redshift,
we have configured data
processing MCP servers.
So all of these tools are available.
Now, LLM is able to decide that,
"Hey, for me to go and
do this quick validation
for the data that is sitting in S3,
Athena seems to be a better choice."
So it used that Athena query
MCP tool in data processing
and went ahead and validated the data.
Now, as a data engineer, if
we were asked to validate,
would we just go with one query
or we would validate
that from various angles?
We would validate that
from multiple angles
to make sure that our data
is data is good to go, right?
That's exactly what Alex is also doing.
So it is trying to validate
the data from multiple angles
so that we don't have any
challenges in the data
that is getting created for the next step.
So looks like all the
validations are done.
And it gives a good
amount of stats as well.
So it has various the states.
And it is also making sure
that all 50 states are,
the data from all 50 states are there.
This is what is the total page views,
this is what is a total amount.
So it gives a quick
validation of what can be done
and making sure that the data is fine.
Cool.
So let's move on to the next one.
So data validation is complete.
Our final step is to go and load this data
into our Redshift.
For that, we are asking Alex,
"Hey, can you go and do
load this to Redshift,
or create a notebook to
load this to Redshift?"
So here, you see that
at this point in time,
it immediately use a Redshift MCP server.
Until now, it has been
using other MCP servers.
The moment we said,
"Hey, I want to load
this data into Redshift,
it used a Redshift MCP
server to list the clusters."
So it is identifying which cluster
because our prompt says go and load this
to analytics Redshift cluster.
So it identified the cluster,
and it is creating a notebook
with all the various
steps that are involved.
And you'll be able to see the notebook
that is getting created right
away in the Kiro IDE itself.
Now, think about the real
challenge that we have.
I think when Harshida was
mentioning about the company
that the challenge that any company had,
one of the challenges
were documentation, right?
And we all face,
we all love to code,
we all love to build the data pipelines,
but we all struggle a bit
to document it well, right?
And that's a challenge that we all have.
And that becomes even more challenging
when we acquire a set of data pipelines
or we transition over to another team
and having to know what is being done.
So if you look at this one,
you see a very detailed notebook
that has a step-by-step
process on how to load,
how to make the connection,
what is a step to load,
validate the data, all of those details,
and some cleanup at the end.
And on the left-hand side,
you can also see a README file,
so that it, by defaults,
create a documentation for you
so that that can be passed on
to any other team member who
is coming into your team.
So, it's creating that the README file
at this point in time.
So that is how you can use these agents
in your day-to-day work when
you do data engineering.
Now, with all of these things,
so we can say that, all right,
so Alex is able to help us
with each one of the activities
that we have asked Alex to do.
Now, in this whole process,
AnyCompany has learned,
had some good learnings as well, right?
So let's talk about that.
Let's talk about some of those things.
One thing that you may
want to keep in mind
is we talked about
configuring multiple services,
multiple servers, MCP servers, right?
Now, each one of these MCP
servers come with various tools.
And it is the LLM, which is
deciding which tool to use
for a particular task that
user is asking the agent to do.
Now, how will the LLM
decide which tool to pick?
It scans through the various tools
and identify what is the best one to pick.
It is always good to, if
you are a data engineer,
you have the control to configure, enable,
or disable the various MCP servers.
It is strongly recommended
to work with the MCP servers
or the number of tools
that you feel that would be more relevant.
Because if you have hundreds
and thousands of tools
that are listed,
your LLM will have to scan through that
and figure out what is
the best one to use.
So you are putting a little
bit more work on the LLM.
So you may want to, as a data engineer,
you might have a good idea.
These are all the MP
servers that I want to use.
So stick to the tools
that you want to use.
That's one thing.
And it's pretty easy to do
that in each one of these IDEs.
For example, SageMaker Unified Studio,
you can either add a MCP
server with a couple of clicks.
In case of Kiro, we saw
that it's a right click
and enabled disabled.
You can go and do that.
OpenSearch has a very
interesting way of doing that.
There's a tool filter
that you can provide.
You can say that, "Hey, I
want to have MCP servers
loaded only for this particular category,
only or this specific task."
So you can be very specific
in the list of tools
that are getting loaded.
So something that you
may want to keep in mind.
The next one is on the
protection of your data
and infrastructure, right?
So each one of the MCP
servers has some good levers
that you must be aware of.
And that's something
that we highly recommend
you all to be aware of.
For example, data processing
MCP server, by default,
it doesn't allow you to go and
create some of the resources
or write the data back
and things like that.
It is designed like that.
So you can go ahead and put allow write
to make sure that your MCP server
is able to do those activities.
Whereas in case of Redshift MCP server,
it's a read-only mode.
So it is intended to consume
the data from Redshift
at this point in time.
And same is the case with OpenSearch,
it is intended to consume
the data from OpenSearch.
When it comes to MSK MCP server,
the persona is slightly different
because that's a control plane
more than the data plane.
The MSK MCP server is
more for a control plane.
It's for an admin persona.
For example, creating a cluster,
or changing the cluster
configuration, and things like that.
That's why the modifications
are, by default, on
in case of MSK cluster.
But you have an option
to go and turn that off.
So please be aware, for each
one of these MCP server,
there are some good
levers that you can use
to protect your data and infrastructure.
So please make use of that.
And the next one is trusting the tools.
And this is what I was mentioning earlier.
So you might have noticed
that in some cases,
the agent was asking, "Hey,
can I go and run this one?"
In some cases, it went ahead
and run, executed those tools.
Why did that happen?
That is because I have
trusted some of the tools.
For example, let's say,
I want to run a query.
If it is going against
my production database,
I wanna see that first.
Or if I'm uploading
something to my S3 bucket,
I wanna see what is getting uploaded.
So it depends on what
is your comfort level,
which environment you
are working on, right?
So depending on what are the
tools that you feel comfortable
that it can go and,
that agent can directly go and run
versus something that you want
a confirmation from your side,
you can configure those
in these various tools.
The left-hand side is
SageMaker Unified Studio.
So you can say that, "Hey,
for this particular tool,
ask me, or always allow."
In case of Kiro, that's where
that block comes into picture,
where you can put a list
of auto-approve tools,
so that it'll automatically be executed
when if the LLM decides
to make use of that tool.
Now, with all of that, no matter what,
human and loop is important.
We cannot emphasize this enough, right?
So please understand that this is,
the agent is there to help,
and it's a consider agent
as a peer programmer, right?
The human in the loop is important,
whether it's read versus write decisions
or what tool is being used.
Or even the code that
it is getting generated
or the query that it is getting generated,
you may want to validate that.
And also there are MCP
servers do have options
to prevent some of these runaway queries
and things like that.
But human in the loop is
important there as well.
So please keep that in mind.
With all that said, we have
looked at all of these pillars
where we see that contact
switching, data quality,
error handling, resource
management, best practices.
The pillars that any company
data engineers mentioned,
the pillars of loss of productivity,
that's been very well-addressed.
We are not saying that all
of these things will be gone,
but it'll be improved,
or it'll be reduced.
These productive productivity
losses will be reduced
with agentic capabilities.
Now, that decision,
here are some of the
results from AnyCompany.
So it is saving a lot of time for sure.
It is productive.
And it is easy to use,
very simple options to configure, right?
And at the end of the
day, yes, it is safe.
There are good number of
flavors to keep everything safe.
Now, yes, it's really good
to have a nice POCN pilot.
How will we scale it?
In case of a data engineering,
it's not really about
taking it to production,
rather it is about scaling it
and making sure that there's
a scalable option out there.
How will you deploy these, right?
So if you have...
If you're just starting with
agentic data engineering,
I would strongly recommend you to get
to SageMaker Unified Studio notebooks
and try out the new
features that was released,
which is a Data Agent.
So here, you have an
agentic AI assistance agent
that is inbuilt in
SageMaker Unified Studio,
which can discover the data,
which can create the various
steps that is involved
for the activities that you want to do
to generate the SQLs or Python code,
or troubleshooting any of the error
that you are getting into.
Pretty much whatever we just
saw what Alex was doing,
that's already in built in
SageMaker Unified Studio.
So please try that out.
Now, there are a lot of customers
who would want to have a
lot more control and lever.
For example, hey, I have
a third-party service
or third-party data source,
and how do I connect to that?
That is where this architecture
that we looked at earlier
comes into picture.
So it's not just about the MCP
servers that are listed here.
Depending on the various data sources
that you want to connect,
you can bring any of these MCP servers.
Now, if you have, let's
say, a 10-member team,
it is very much okay to have
each one of your developers
have the respective, let's say,
all of them are using Kiro,
them going and configuring that mcp.json
and working with these MCP servers.
It could be the same set of MCP servers,
it could be different set of MCP servers.
That's perfectly fine.
That's a widely accepted pattern.
Now, there are cases
where you may want to
have an agent deployed
and roll it out to the whole organization.
How would you do that?
That's where AgentCore,
Bedrock AgentCore comes into picture.
And in this session,
we will not be doing a deep
dive on AgentCore per se.
But just to give you an example,
or give you a little bit more details.
So here, Bedrock AgentCore
has multiple components to it.
The Runtime helps you to deploy an agent.
And the one on the left-hand side,
which is the AgentCore Memory,
helps you to keep track
of the conversations
that you're having.
So that's what is AgentCore Memory does.
Similarly, if you are
working with an agent,
we may want to know
everything that is happening.
So traceability is important.
So that's where the Observability
comes into the picture, right?
AgentCore Observability
will give you those details.
And AgentCore Identity will help you
to do the user authentication.
Now, Gateway, the crux of it,
is we talked about the
various MCP servers.
Now you have an option to go ahead
and configure various MCP
servers using Gateway,
so that when the LLM gets
a request from the user,
it can go to Gateway, find out,
out of the whole list of tools,
what is the tool that it wants to use
for the next best action.
So, this is an architecture.
And you can see other tools
that are getting added
to the Gateway as well.
So you may have some custom tools
that you have built in your organization,
which you wanna bring in as well.
So AgentCore Gateway helps
you to do that as well.
So this is an architecture
that you can use
if you want to scale it out.
Or if you have a very specific agent,
let's say, data analysis agent
or data engineering agent that
you want to bring or deploy
and roll it out to your
entire organization.
Now, with all that said,
going back to Sarah, our CTO,
she feels that, yes,
everything looks good.
The pilot went very well.
The results are good.
And at the same time,
she clearly see a path forward
to deploy this at scale.
And the recommendation was to move forward
and fully roll out the agentic capability
to all the work streams.
Now, we really hope
that you'll be able to
take these learnings
and implement some of these things
in your day-to-day activities
in your organization.
And we want to leave
you with some resources.
Here are some of the resources.
The first one is on the
list of MCP servers.
We have a couple of
blogs on data processing
and Redshift MCP blogs.
And the one on the bottom,
the left, is the data agent,
the SageMaker Unified Studio AI agent.
And we have a QR code for
the AgentCore as well.
Cool.
And at Amazon,
we strongly feel that we
should always keep learning
and be curious.
And here is a way to
learn more about agents.
Hope you'll be able to learn
more about agents as well.
And thank you.
And please, share what you
thought about the session.
Please fill in your survey
because we really care about that.
And we'll be around to talk to you
on any questions that you may have,
because as a silent session,
we may not be able to
take the live questions,
but we'll be around to talk to you.
All right, thank you.